you
okay this is the the second part of my
presentation and as I said before we
talked about the legends the myths of
language learning and now we're going to
talk about methods and cognitive
principles or just principles of
learning now the question is the very
first question is do we learn can we
learn how kids learn languages a common
suggestion is that we should learn like
kids do that is called the natural way
now it's a fact that without a doubt
kids end up learning a language very
well but the wrong conclusion that
people draw or some people draw is that
if you learn like a kid or try to learn
like a kid you will succeed now let me
start by saying that in general the
conditions in which kids and adults
learn languages are quite different
first of all kids don't have another
language they have just one language
they don't have another language like
adults influencing the language you're
learning and as I said before they have
no choice but to learn because they live
the language so the main difference is
that learning your first language is the
result of living it's not the result of
a choice you make to learn another
language and normally when you have no
choice you cannot make a bad choice but
adults can actually make the wrong
choice and they can learn the wrong way
and they can give up but this doesn't
necessarily mean that kids learn better
and faster now in English there's an
expression when you say that you're
comparing apples with oranges it means
that you're comparing things that have
nothing to do with one another and
that's the case of language learning for
adults and for kids now I believe that a
fair comparison should be done in the
same conditions now it's true that
adults have some disadvantages but we
don't have enormous
disadvantages so let's look at the way
kids learn a language first and in what
conditions now first of all as Richard
said before they are they have a family
and this means that kids are surrounded
by the language since they are born this
implies affection from your mother from
your father but also playing time in
natural and genuine curiosity with the
world and this psychological factor
plays a huge role in language learning
and then we all go to school and in
school we learn a second language in a
formal context we interact with our
classmates we get corrected by our
teacher when we speak and when we write
so learning a language is also the
result of a social interaction with your
peers with your classmates and with
other learners and then we all like
watching movies listening to the radio
listening to music and we spend a lot of
time without even thinking about it we
spend a lot of time listening to the
language and then of course we have a
lot of friends though this helps us
learn a language as kids now if we do
the math a year normally is like 365 day
let's suppose that we're considering a
18 year old kid so times 18 years and
then 24 hours because the brain learns
even when we're sleeping and this is
almost 80,000 hours of reading listening
speaking and living the language
everything happens as a whole process in
the course of a long time now let's
consider the conditions in which adults
learn languages first of all we have
interference from our native language
and this implies interference in grammar
syntax pronunciation and so on and then
kids are more genuinely curious than us
we are still curious but a little
differently than them as I said before
adults have problems psychological
problems when they have to speak when
they fear making mistakes they fear
being judged by others
and there are other factors like we have
less time we don't have an environment
surrounding us and where the language is
constantly spoken
we have other commitments in life we
have a job we have to do a lot of things
in our life and we're generally busy
so this basically means that comparing
is difficult because conditions are
different first of all because as I said
before there are some internal
psychological factors like the one isit
talked about before having no language
means that you can learn any other
language you have no interference and
then there's this emotional connection
with the world in which the language is
spoken that plays a huge role and then
apart from the psychological internal
factors there are also the external
environmental factors now if you any of
you go living in say Italy for eighteen
years and then you hear you listen you
speak you go to school you get corrected
if you follow exactly the same pattern
the path that kids followed I am sure
that you will speak the language quite
well and you will reach maybe you will
not reach a native level but you will
reach a very high level that will allow
you to do whatever you want to do in
that language now how do we learn a
second language well first of all we
most of us don't go living in another
country we stay in our own country so
how can we learn a language as
independent learners in the comfort of
our home now as I said before the bad
news is that we don't have all the
advantages that kid have but there's
also good news because we have some
advantages as adults now when we start
doing something whatever it is I think
it's very important to start with the
right mindset and obviously you have to
make the right choices now on the
Internet
there's a lot of people asking
themselves what is the the best method
to learn a language now the problem is
that searching for
a universal objective efficient method
is pointless let me explain you why now
the reason why there is no one best
method is because every each and every
one of you have a different learning
style and different tastes what is good
for me
am I not good for you it's a trial and
error process it means that you have to
try and you have to see what suits you
best since the very beginning so an
important principle is to figure out
what you like it sounds a very beginning
now before delving and talking about
methods let me talk about basic
cognitive principles the very first
thing the very important thing is
attitude have having a positive mindset
is very important and you have to know
since the very beginning that learning
languages is fun and it's not difficult
as difficult as people think so the
attitude that you have not only towards
the language but also towards the people
plays a very very important role in
language learning
now the psychological factor is as I
said before absolutely essential you
have to know your limits we are all
human beings we all make mistakes so if
we know that we have limits it can be
our force make the time now one of the
most common excuses for language
learners is that they say I don't have
the time to learn a language quintillion
who was a Roman rhetorician said it is
not that we don't have time it is that
we make poor use of it and he was right
I think because we always find time to
do things that we like so the next
question would be how do we make the
time as you can see that that small
thing there is which is a portable
device as you know a real revolution for
language learning because you can use it
anywhere and whenever you want it
obviously you have to want it you can do
it while walking driving the car washing
the dishes and even when you go to the
supermarket
now another very important principle is
consistency that means that in order to
be successful you have to learn every
single day and possibly even twice a day
for example spending 30 minutes
deliberately studying for example
listening and reading something when you
feel fresh and weekends for example when
you don't work and if you're a little
bit tired or you're doing something else
you can use your debt time by listening
to portable devices and I showed you
this at the example before like when you
go to the supermarket when you're at
home cleaning up or washing the dishes
etc the big advantage of this of
studying every single day is that you
are feeding the brain you're giving it
food and another important thing is that
the brain normally learns with small
chunks of information so people might
think that if they spend 10 hours
learning a language every day it's
actually better than spending 30 minutes
but when you spend too much time doing
something your level of concentration
goes down you have the impression that
you're learning a lot but you're not
learning efficiently and you don't burn
out burnt out means that you are tired
sick and tired of the language and you
don't want to learn it anymore which is
a very common mistake that people make
now another principle is the fact that
in the input that is what you read and
what you listen to has to be
intelligible you have to understand it
and as I said before it has to be
interesting another very important thing
is that you have to vary your work
because if you always do the same thing
then it gets boring for example when you
have a text in front of your eyes and
you keep reading and reading it or just
your activity you're learnt language
learning activity is reading then it
gets boring so if you consider a text so
a piece of information and you have
audio as well you can not only read it
if you think about it you can also read
and listen at the same time you can just
listen to it
or you can even read it out loud
speak to yourself by using the things
that you have seen in the text so what
counts is not only how much you do
things but also how you do things the
advantages are that listening a reading
at the same time is an easy thing to do
everybody can do it and when you change
and vary your operations and your
activities it keeps you interested and
motivated like in all schools in the
world language is one of the subjects
that you have to study a foreign
language and unfortunately sometimes
it's considered most of the times I
would say it's considered like another
subject to study but as I said before
languages have to be learned they don't
have to be studied you cannot study a
language you can only learn it a very
important thing is rote memorization
that means when you learn things by
heart so you think that learning by
heart is a good thing like when they
tell you you can learn for example a
poetry by heart but speaking in language
is actually the ability of assembling
blocks assembling bricks in order to
produce something you learn by repeating
things varying things and getting
exposed to content obviously so the
bottom line of this is that you don't
learn grammar and you learn grammar and
words from context if you think about it
that's exactly what kids to you learn by
repeating by revising things not by
learning things by heart another very
important thing is motivation if you
have a beautiful Ferrari but you don't
have any fuel in it it's like having no
Ferrari at all
so most people give up after some time
because they don't know how to keep
themselves interesting to keep
themselves motivated a an easy thing to
do this to motivate yourself is to think
about what you can do with only some
months of studying you can travel all
around the world and it makes speaking
languages makes your life easier you can
talk to people you can read interesting
books about the culture of that country
or that language you can watch
interesting documentaries or movies and
television and for the most romantic
to give you you can even find love an
obviously friendship which is an
important thing in life so every time
you start learning in your learning
session think about all about all the
amazing things that you can do in your
life this means that actually languages
can change your life and they changed
mine another principle is action
learning speaking languages interacting
with human beings is actually the art of
imperfection each and every one of you
have tried to babble in the language and
trying to say something and at the
beginning was difficult each one of you
each and every one of you made mistakes
when trying to come across your ideas
and kids make a lot of mistakes before
they learn to speak a language well so
you have to accept your limits and to
know that in order to do something well
you first have to do it poorly ie in my
experience I find a lot of so-called
perfectionists that is people who want
to speak the language perfectly since
the very beginning and I think that
perfectionism is actually not a good
thing when it comes to language learning
so when it comes to talking to people
speaking to people you have to feel
ready and when you feel ready you can
start for example talking to yourself
what some people might think that you
have become completely crazy if they see
you speaking to yourself on the street
but actually I found out that a lot of
people do it for example when taking a
shower and speaking to yourself is not a
far-fetched it's not a crazy idea it's
actually a very effective one and of
course as I said before you can always
find a partner online or in life with
whom you can interact for example you
can exchange a language for another so
the bottom line of this is that language
is a communication tool it is something
we use to talk to other people and we
perfect it by using it and when we do it
becomes an automatic process you don't
think when you speak Russian you just
speak it this is not only for your
native tongue but also for other
languages that you want to learn so
there is no best language path that you
can follow but there is your language
path it means that when
we have for example to go from point A
to point B there are all sorts of
possible ways to reach that point a
proof of that is that evidence of that
is the fact that for example I or
Richard we have learned languages in
very different ways yet I think we both
learn it well so another thing is that
you have to try to find your own
language path now this is my personal
language path so it's not Universal but
that's what I normally do with languages
here on the axis you can see T which
stands for time and this is the
efficiency with which you learn and it
depends on time
so at the beginning that this is
so-called the beginner phase what
happens is that you start learning a
language slowly that's the way I do it
it means that I decide to learn slowly
because the language is unknown but then
when you have a feeling of the language
it becomes a little bit more familiar
but something amazing happens in your
brain which people call the epiphany
point where you have develop a feel for
the language it's in your head you can
use it and when that happens you can
learn faster without even realizing it
by using the language that means that
the language is automatic is an
automatic cognitive process so if we
consider every single stage at the
beginning the language is totally
unknown and the advice that I give you
as I said before is to work a little bit
every single day the content that you
can start with when you learn a language
can be for example language series like
books that help you learn a language at
the beginning my personal method is to
use for example bilingual texts if I
want to learn Russia for example I would
choose make sure that I always have a
text in Italian or some other language
that helps me understand the text in
Russian and then I use a special
technique which is called bilingual
translation that helps me retain extract
the information and keep it in my head
and
the principle here is that it's better
to put quality in your work at the very
beginning and the goal is to train
myself to get a solid foundation of the
language now when you have learned and
you have a solid foundation of the
language it becomes a little bit more
automatic and when you start doing that
you don't even think about it you just
use it and in this phase I create and
choose as I said before monolingual and
bilingual text I create them through the
internet
I still use bilingual translation but I
also read a lot more and the principles
are not only quality but also quantity
and the goal is to build a language core
in your head now when you have reached a
certain level the language becomes very
familiar and this means that you can
actually do all sorts of things and not
even think about it time is not a
problem anymore in this phase what I use
for example is TV movies and obviously
native speakers because interaction
human interaction is important so the
method basically in this phase is that I
create my own environment where I can
use the language every single time in
all possible situations that means that
I use the language constantly my goal
which is an ambitious goal obviously is
to reach a native-like fluency but
obviously we never start we never stop
learning we always learn well the reason
why it is effective in a found I find
out about it later is that it respects
the burrito principle it means that you
learned something a little bit and you
learn it well and that helps you to
learn the other part of the language
which is actually 80% of the rest that's
the reason why it's called the 2080
principle learning a language is not a
linear process for example you don't
learn you don't first learn all the
colors and then you learn all the other
parts etc it's something that comes
randomly at you it's not linear but it's
progressive it means that you keep
progressing and a good thing is that my
method changes with time I don't always
do the same things in the different
phases and it's consistent that means
that I
use it in a certain way and it has to
respect the principles of consistency
and it adapts to my way of learning my
tastes it's constant because they do it
every single day once they start
learning a language and it's very
because I do all sorts of things with a
language not use one and it's obviously
fun it's entertaining I find it very
entertaining so the conclusion is that
language learning is not difficult and
it can be fun and another thing that you
always have to keep in mind is that it
can change your life and it can be done
if you know how to do it and another
very good news is that Internet is a
revolution and it has changed the way we
can learn so the last thing that I
wanted to tell you is happy language
learning